Okay, great job with the refactoring
to normalize the shopping lists.
While you were working on that,
I made two new screens for sharing.
Let me show you what they look like.
You might have remembered the sharing
flow from when I mentioned it before.
So you have some list open.
Let's say a generic grocery list.
And you can click the share icon.
The Share icon will take you to
the new Share List activity that I've
created for you.
Here you'll see a list of your friends.
And if you want to add a new friend,
you can click the Add New Friend button.
This takes you to
the Add Friend activity,
which has a list of
all users in the app.
If you want to add one
of them as a friend,
you simply need to click
their email address, and
you'll be taken back to the Share List
activity with the new friend added.
Things get more complicated when you
actually want to start sharing the lists
with these friends.
But for now, let's start with just this
ShareList AddFriendActivity interaction.
All that I want is for you to make it so
when you click add friend,
you see a list of users,
you could select the user, and
then they end up here in the ShareList.
Right now, displaying the list of all
users of the app should be pretty
straightforward.
After all, you know how to
use Firebase list of actors.
And you have a location in your Firebase
database that contains a list of
all users.
But what about this
list of friends here?
Remember that our database design
included a node called user friends,
which I've been told I
haven't talked much about.
Let's take a look at that node
in the database design schema.
So here's the database design
that we're going for, and
we can see the user friends node here.
If we expand it, you'll see that we're
going to have a list of user emails.
For every user that has friends,
they'll be a list.
And then under each user email,
they'll be a list of friend emails.
You can go ahead and
put an entire user object here, so
that you'll have access
to the user's name.
So getting that list of users that you
need to show on the sharing screen
is a simple as attaching
a list right here.
To the encoded email of the user
that you're interested in.
Okay, I'm excited for you to add these
new screens, and I'm sending over
the exact specifications, and
the code, for the new screens now.